[Music]
foreign
[Music]
the law side
all the way through until my
incarceration I mean I'm looking at it
like this is my life this is what I do
and uh I'm gonna try to make the best of
it the best way I can and you said you
had been incarcerated or you had you
know you had been locked up all those
times when you were young what were the
typical charges I mean was it the full
gamut yes I mean I I first got locked if
I was seven it was for stealing you mean
I had seven yes sir I couldn't get
locked up because
I was seven you got to be eight before
you even could be private nine you know
yeah so as you went out we wound up in
the same Juvenile Facility
Juvenile Facility
you mean but uh and that's all the way
through I mean as a as an adult I was
locked up 30 something times with
different charges what were you locked
up for when you were 11 what were you
sent to the juvenile facility for oh
truancy
you know not going to school doing this
and doing that you know not aband nobody
you know so you go down in 30 days
okay he come home
you know you you learn different things
still learn to hustle because now in the
Performing school you're not afraid of
it because you didn't just got through
it
you know that's how I became the guy
that I became the guy you know the
reputation that I acquired what is the
reputation tough guy yeah it's just that
you know I mean not the typical I'm not
going to do nothing rotten to nobody you
know but you ain't taking nothing
yeah that was our you know you can't we
making a lot of money
and when you make a lot of money a lot
of people try to take it
and
we you can't do that over here
that's the kind of a a fear or that's
kind of uh the way you have to be in the
street
if you ain't going to do them what
they're going to do to you you know
since you've been there um
it wasn't just on that side it's even if
somebody was connected to you I mean if
if everybody in this room in this room
we all look okay I mean just you just
ain't gonna do nothing to me you ain't
gonna do nothing to nobody in here
you mean if you do something to anybody
in there I mean you'll see everybody we
had 24 guys
uh went to court with us
you couldn't do nothing none of them
that's just
this is how it is and that was for the
the that was in the 80s when we were
1780s 70s and 80s yeah but for when you
said went to court with you for the for
the indictment that that eventually how
many how many years did you do
ultimately 37 37 and and 29 9.
29 30 years and so in that case there
was there's 24 of you yeah and and what
were those those charges were were what
like Rico charges yeah
848 for me and him
yeah
then it it was for another guy magic 848
and then the charges dropped down to
conspiracy distribution you mean stuff
like that but there were three of us
that got the 48 one of my one of the
guys that's not here he got two 848s wow
I mean you got one with us and then he
got one because he stayed out in the
street he caught another 848. so can you
guys explain what that is a48 can you
guys that's right it's a it's a criminal
code it's the uh Federal Criminal for
running and continuing criminal
Enterprise which has to have a certain
amount of money I would say uh five
million at the lowest end and and
violence as well so yeah it's it's it's
a it's the Kingpin charge Kingpin charge
it doesn't get any higher than that at
all
you know what was so unique about
peanut in their crew
everybody did their time
nobody told
nowadays [ __ ] get glorified and
telling being a rat is like such an
amazing thing nowadays
they stuck to that old school code you
do what you do
shut up and do your time as a man nobody
told in that group and is that is that
the way that you guys look at it is that
is that part of being a man no the way
it was it's about being fair it ain't
about being a tough guy or Oh you mean
you you kill people or you do too many
bad [ __ ] to people the thing is about
like you just be fair as much as you can
to everybody so I mean it won't be no
animosity towards you according to what
comes back
from where if something happened to them
you know so by being fair and being
helpful uh to everybody that seem like I
mean they don't have a real reason
to do nothing to you you do something
dirty to somebody then this [ __ ] happens
to the first thing they say is well you
can get rid of them by telling them
you mean so you can tell but it was
somebody that did you mean all good to
you uh you start to look at it different
and out of a big case with a bunch of
money involved that they couldn't get
one person uh to tell on the inside and
look I I know because I I know what your
your commitment is now and and like what
these what these guys are saying is
you've always been committed to your
community and you're playing the cards
that you were dealt and you gave back I
understand that I know that that's what
your commitment is now as well and you
want to do it in a different way
um and I I fundamentally believe it's a
it's a theme that we keep kind of going
back to on on this show that only if
you've really been in that Valley can
you really talk to others that might be
in it to try to lift them out of it and
try to show them a different way that no
one's going to listen to somebody who
hasn't been there
can you tell me just sort of the other
side of that like where were described
to me a little bit about your guys lives
say in the 1970s what did what did that
look like what you know what what what
kind of money what kind of Lifestyle
what what was that like and I want to
know like you know during that during
the peak of that would you guys say you
were happy
yeah
can you explain that because because
because
the enjoyment that you get out of having
money yeah you know all the all like I
said again the Devil's Playground he got
everything strip clubs he got you know
you know drugs you got women you got
everything you want to be peanut kid
ain't gonna make you that but you got
consequences that come with that what
are those consequences jail or death
or you want to say your soul
you know one of the others so you know
but if if if if if you're not looking
like at that you know the jail or the
death and you're you're part of the
street and you're part of the devil
Flicker and you and you playing by his
rules
it's nothing you can do everything has
to be everything has to be
you have to take care of everything you
have to take care of man because
you can get it and you know me I ain't
never been shots there going out y'all
[Laughter]
why is that it's how you gotta put that
thing yeah yeah
I'm fast
you're pretty yeah fast
do you believe if you've sold your soul
to the devil do you believe if you've
done that do you believe that there's a
way to buy it back no I don't know no no
you ain't getting that bad because he
don't need no money he don't need
nothing
yeah well he want is pain and misery
that's all they want and that's all we
was you know you dishing out you got to
do what he said you when and when you
finish you can get out
you ain't got to pay nothing to get in
but you got to pay to get out
you gonna pay
so is you going is you gonna pay for the
30
years that we done or is you gonna pay
land in that Prime box
he wants you crying
and you know what you have anything like
that you can't give him nothing
you know but so but if you go if you if
you graduate to the other side of that
I want to positive and and understand
that side also and that's where we come
in as we do is just talking about
you you looking at both sides you can
you recognize it enormous ability to
serve you have enormous power there
there's a million people all over this
country all over this world that engage
in illegal activity people that are in
circumstances that were probably similar
to to yours I knew people that I grew up
with and where I grew up everybody right
but but there's something about what you
guys did that Kingpin thing that's a
little there's not too many of those can
you tell me what was unique I looked
like in the 70s for me it was
really the stepping stone to really get
out there I mean I met Joe in I think
with 72 again we was up Hagerstown they
called I like to pin upon and we got
together through a crab game no I'm
sorry and this is why you were
incarcerated yes this is why I was
incarcerated we got together but I made
my mind up and go before I went to
prison at uh I was 17 then that [ __ ] was
so off that it got to be another way to
get all this stuff done you mean because
it wasn't making no sense she'd give you
all in all and and you don't get [ __ ] in
return and at the end of the day you
start off again tomorrow you don't have
anything to show for yeah and it
continues that way right so after going
and getting incarcerated you mean you
start to have time to evaluate things we
met in 72
uh I think we're through a crack game we
was going to beat some other guy
and then we got together
and knocked them off and then after that
we start to grow and start sharing ideas
and stuff like that I got home before
him
uh in the same music now
yes in fact what happened
did you come home where I came to get
you I came there I came in the halfway
house and uh I came to met you up by you
by your house okay we talked
you know what was that conversation
conversation about what we was going to
do you know you always get guys and they
locked up you know when we get out man
we're gonna get together and do this
again and we did that for real
[Music]
all right
foreign